STEPHANIE WONG:
Hey, it's Stephanie,
and welcome to the Google
Cloud Tech YouTube channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Have you ever wondered
how machine learning
can make you a
better athlete or how
a data center looks and works?
Curious about how to speed
up your app development?
Need to stay up to date with
Google Cloud's latest updates
and product launches?
If the answer is yes to
any of these questions,
you've come to the right place.
Whether you are a seasoned
engineer or just starting out
on your developer journey, every
day our team of Cloud experts
release new videos to
educate, inspire, and inform
developers of all skill
sets and experiences.
Subscribe to the channel
today and join our community
to learn what the
Cloud can do for you.